hundreds of authors come to the ucla
campus every spring for the los angeles
times festival of books
and inside the book tv bus today we have
professor john weiner he is the author
of this book historians in trouble
plagiarism fraud and politics in the
ivory tower why are historians in
trouble
well it's great to be with you today
even though this topic is a unhappy one
um why is it unhappy there's more more
news over the last year or two about
plagiarism fraud and other kinds of
misconduct by authors
than there has been for a long time and
it's hard to figure out if that's just
kind of the current media
obsession or or if something has changed
but certainly it doesn't make historians
look good when some of their
best-selling
representatives turn out to be guilty of
some of these forms of misconduct how
did you get interested in writing about
this
uh well i'm a contributing editor to the
nation magazine that's america's oldest
weekly
and this sort of my beat was
academic life the politics of the
university
and some of these stories had come up uh
in a way that
we thought they should be covered so it
started out as journalism for weekly
magazine
uh nation of course being a magazine on
the left is kind of interested in the
political angle on all of these and then
it seemed to me there were some bigger
connections between these different uh
episodes that merited uh
expanding the whole project into a book
and what are those bigger connections
well there's a fascinating pattern of
what leads
historians are accused of misconduct
intermittently
some of them have their careers ruined
they're fired no one will publish their
books others who seem to have committed
equally serious offenses
get ignored and shrugged off nobody
seems to care and still others
far from being ignored get rewarded get
prizes and honors so i had to ask the
question
it doesn't if it's not the seriousness
of the offense that determines the
outcome what
is it
let's step back and do an example of
each one of the ones that you just
mentioned
um give us an example of one in which
the historian's uh career is basically
over because well the best example there
is the historian of guns in america a
guy named michael beliel he was a
tenured full professor at emory
and his book was called arming america
there were certain let us say problems
in some of his documentation
he was attacked
his thesis was
that the founding fathers
that in early america
there hadn't been a lot of guns to be
protected by the second amendment in
fact he argued there were very few guns
in early america uh
and he had lots of different ways of
showing this and that that cast the
second amendment in a very different
light america was not a gun-toting
gun-loving
country in its origins he said the
origins of our gun culture are much more
recent he dated it to the civil war era
well the the nra and the gun lobby uh
objected to this and
instead of
going after his argument they went after
his footnotes
they his footnotes have been checked
more carefully than probably any author
of the last five or ten years and sure
enough there's a lot of gaps
inconsistencies problems in his
footnotes the question is how serious is
that
his critic said this is extremely
serious uh his defender said everybody
makes mistakes it doesn't change his
thesis is understandable
it's not good
but
in the end emery
uh decided uh to get rid of him in fact
he i believe resigned instead of being
fired as far as i know michael bill is
not employed as a professor uh anymore
so there's a person whose career was
ended
because of the charges of
research fraud
now the next one
well uh one of his colleagues at emory
elizabeth fox genovese who was the head
of the women's studies program there
uh was charged uh with uh
sexual harassment and sexual
discrimination
by her assistant
uh this was quite big news um in atlanta
and uh was going to be on
national tv it was going to trial
but emory decided to settle the case
paid a large undisclosed sum to the
assistant
elizabeth fox genovese went on to be
awarded the national humanities medal in
the east room of the white house by
president bush
so far from the this what seemed to be
scandal hurting a career
conservative
magazines portrayed her as a
victim of feminist political correctness
and said that her courage in standing up
to these
feminazis i believe is how rush limbaugh
described them she should be a hero and
should be honored and indeed she was
and then an example of historian that
might have done something but it just
didn't rise to the level where it got
well yeah there's one other guy
who uh
wrote a book about a famous slave
uprising in uh charleston in uh
before the civil war the denmark vc
slave uprising
he
he published what he said was the
transcript of the trial of the accused
slaves another historian went back to
this document found
he'd done it completely wrong there in
fact there was no trial
the evidence against him
actually all came from a very tainted
source far from being a hero
of black freedom and resistance he was
more the victim
of a power struggle among the white
elite so it seemed like he had the story
exactly backwards
the article that exposed this problem
won the prize for being the best article
in american history journals of of the
year
but
other than a few civil wars a few few
historians of slavery
nobody really cared and
the book was withdrawn from publication
by the publisher because it was so error
written but aside from that nobody knows
about this except me and now you
so what was your conclusion what were
the the combining elements of well my
conclusion was that it's not the
seriousness of the of the misconduct
that determines the fate of the accused
what determines the fate of the accused
is the power of the accusers and the
defenders it's a political issue
and the um
basically the right has been much more
effective at going after people it feels
uh or it objects to at defending people
it considers its allies
and uh
and the people it doesn't care about
basically nothing much happens to so
basically it's not the nature of the
misconduct it's the power of the
supporters in the opponents that
determines what happens to historians
accused of misconduct and what's the
role of the media in all of this well
the media of course is is crucial
some of these things
end up on page one michael beliel the
historian of guns that story was on page
one of the new york times it seems kind
of wild like
why does the new york times care
about a dispute over a scholarly book
so
the big question is whose agenda gets
into the media is the media story
you know honest hard-working historian
horribly mistreated by right-wing cabal
or or is it
a
gun historian guilty of terrible crimes
um once again
the pattern seems to be that the right
has been more effective than the left at
framing the stories that are told in the
media at least in the cases that i
studied do you know why the right has
been more effective in your opinion well
they're uh
i don't know they've they've
they
that's a very good question
because the left has been trying to do
this the right has a more
organized more systematic and i guess we
have to say better funded operation of
you know think tanks
publications um and
networks and
they have
succeeded at that it's taken them 20
years to develop it but they set their
goals
in that direction 20 years ago and and
today they're quite effective at it take
what you just said and talk through the
story of doris kearns goodwin a very
high profile historian doris kearns
goodwin was
accused of plagiarism for her her book
the kennedys and the fitzgeralds
now it turned out that the long passages
from in her book had actually appeared
in somebody else's book several years uh
before
um she said her research is this usually
what you say when this happens is my
research assistant didn't you know
footnote properly
uh but in doris goodwin's case
it was actually much more serious
because her book
was sent for review
to the person she had plagiarized from
quite unusual so she sent
her
her publisher some no i believe it was
some uh a
book review uh sent it out for review
uh and that person then contacted doris
kearns goodwin and her publisher and
said you know i have to tell you that
this is my work in this book
so they had a series of meetings and
what happened was the the victim of the
plagiarism
agreed to accept a cash
uh settlement in compensation for this
offense that's the way we solve a lot of
disputes in america but part of the
agreement was that in exchange for the
money
this
victim of plagiarism would agree to be
silent about what had happened and in
fact not only made that agreement but
went on to give the book a good review
and it wasn't until a decade later that
somebody going back over this whole
episode
found out the true story of what had
happened now in my opinion it's much
more serious to pay for the silence of
an accuser than it is to borrow someone
else's words and claim claim them as
your own now doris kearns goodwin did
pay a price for this as i recall she
was forced to resign from the harvard
board of overseers i believe
she lost her uh slot as a commentator on
mcneil lehrer was it or something like
that
uh but then within about two years she
was back on tv as a commentator on on
msnbc or something like that during the
last convention so and now she has a new
book out and it's quite a good book and
she's back on the book circuit and
everybody's forgotten about this one
except me and you so but how did that
would you call it forgiveness why would
doris kearns goodwin get
a pass on this or or you know after a
couple years it'd be forgotten and
others wouldn't well partly she
she pled guilty and paid a price she
gave up this harvard position she did
lose her tv
slot partly um i i believe
she had a kind of uh
publicity pr
counter offensive where she went on
letterman or something like that and you
know told her story and
was appropriately apologetic and partly
she's a good writer and a popular person
and everybody forgives her because they
like her and they like her books
does it does it help for her to have
many friends in the media and it was
that anything that had to do with this
yes she's a well-connected uh media
person for many you know a decade or two
and that certainly gives her
the the kind of connections that that
help when you're trying to rehabilitate
yourself after one of these kinds of
episodes joseph ellis what happened and
how did that play out in terms of uh
your uh your subjects
this is one of the the wilder and harder
to explain cases um joe ellis famous
historian of early america best seller
award-winning award winner
the problem with joe ellis
was not in anything he published it was
in his teaching
at mount holyoke college in western mass
he had been telling he was a famous
professor of a a course on the history
of the vietnam war and he told his
students that he had fought in the
vietnam war and he gave them vivid
descriptions of what it was like there
and students consider this part of one
of the most memorable uh courses they'd
ever taken were very moved and
told their parents about it
well it turned out the boston globe
discovered joe ellis had never fought in
vietnam joe ellis had been a on the
faculty of uh west point i think it was
and this was
he just made this up
uh now
some people said well he didn't
uh he didn't lie in his books he didn't
steal anybody else's words so what's the
big deal
my view was
lying to your students
misleading your students being dishonest
with your students is just as serious as
lying to your readers or being dishonest
with your readers and it should be taken
as a very serious
offense it's kind of a nutty one
um it certainly is
pretty unique as far as i know well
mount holyoke was horribly embarrassed
because he was maybe their most famous
faculty member
uh but they you know uh held
disciplinary hearings and committees
studied this and he was he was punished
he
he was
sent into exile for a year his chair he
was i think ford foundation professor or
something like that his endowed chair
was taken away
and he's never allowed to teach his
course on vietnam again
so he he was shamed he was punished uh
and
i believe he has a new book out and you
know he's he's back on the book circuit
and teaching again and there's another
episode that's over
what type of oversight do historians
have in this country and should it be
stronger or who you mentioned that the
media caught some of these but what is
the oversight well the
this is a very troubled area right now
the american historical association is
chartered by congress
and it's supposed to play a role like
the american medical association or the
or the the american bar association it's
supposed to among other things
police the profession
now if you're a doctor or a lawyer you
know you can be disbarred or your
license can be taken away
what actually happens if you're a
historian can you take away you can't
take away a person's license to be a
historian well the american historical
association had
a a disciplinary committee that
investigated complaints of plagiarism
and other forms of misconduct took
testimony and issued rulings
but as our society and our history
profession became more litigious they
got more and more nervous
that they lacked the legal resources to
to do this in a
with the proper jurisprudence they were
worried about being sued for libeling
people they were investigating and a
couple of years ago they just gave it
all up they said
it's too risky for us we don't have the
resources we can't do this right
we will no longer
adjudicate charges of professional
misconduct by historians instead they
said this is up to the universities that
employ the historians they're the ones
who have deep pockets they're the ones
that have the power to punish or to
render verdicts of innocent they can
fire people they can dock their pay they
could like they did with joe ellis they
were impressed by some of these cases
and said well the universities can do
this better than we can
but not all universities can smaller
places or or people who who
who aren't
you know uh in high profile departments
stephen ambrose is an interesting case
he died but stephen ambrose the
historian of d-day you know incredible
bestseller millions of people have read
his books
he plagiarized his his book about bomber
pilots in in world war ii was
plagiarized from somebody else's book
and
uh
when he was confronted by this he said
i'm a writer
i write books
if you don't like my books don't read
them
that's it he said think what you can
think of me whatever you want
he wasn't part of a university he wasn't
subject to any disciplinary proceedings
in a way it's kind of refreshing you
know an objection to me
fine don't buy my books
um
so that's sort of where it stands now if
you work for a university your
university may
in charge and somebody bothers to tell
your university that you're charged with
some kind of research misconduct
universities may investigate you
and may punish you or judge you innocent
but in a lot of cases that seems
unlikely to happen so i sort of regret
the fact that the american historical
association has given up the role of
adjudicating this kind of
a charge to what degreed are um
universities likely not to want to know
this information or not to want it to be
released because
isn't that professorship kind of
important to them in terms of their
national recognition excellent question
university's biggest preoccupation with
this sort of thing is protecting
themselves
from litigation from damage suits and
they their lawyers are telling them make
these things go away let's not make this
public
we don't want to be charged with
libeling our faculty members
so they prefer
very quiet behind the scenes
negotiations your lawyers meet with my
lawyers and we'll work this out and part
of the working out will be a
confidentiality agreement among all
parties
well
maybe that does head off some
possibility of some kind of
libel
litigation afterwards but what about the
public what about the readers who want
to know hey whatever happened to that
dispute is this book plagiarized there
isn't is this person a legitimate
historian or is this person a fraud
uh universities are really reluctant in
many cases unless they're really pressed
to have a public discipline of of their
faculty members
that still leaves the question of who
investigates this who finds it out in
the fir in in the first place you
mentioned the media in practice it's a
lot of this has been left up to the
media um should it be
well the media of course has its agendas
too uh it plays favorites um of course
plagiarism stories are very hot right
now so uh if you've got a plagiarism
story you can you can keep it going
for a while but a lot of these stories
it was because
either a magazine on the right or a
magazine on the left
set out to make a case against somebody
and
sometimes these cases had substance
sometimes they they were right but the
media is not really a neutral uh
arbitrator the media has its own
interests first of all in making stories
big
making celebrities uh you know
playing off the celebrity of famous
people to
get eyeballs to their website or get
people to to buy their publications so
that doesn't seem to be a very good way
to do it either
the archivist of the united states
who is he alan weinstein is his name he
um
this is another case that's never really
been resolved allen weinstein wrote
what many people regard as the
definitive book about the alger his case
altra his was a prominent
new deal liberal official in the fdr
administration
who was
accused of being a soviet spy by a
former communist named whitaker chambers
this was in the late 40s
and eventually alger hiss was was
convicted not of spying but of perjury
and served time in prison went to his
death proclaiming his innocence
alan weinstein before he became
archivist of the united states wrote a
book purporting to show that elder hiss
was guilty and the alger his was a liar
but then
the nation magazine
which had been a defender of his back in
the 50s
went to the people who would be part
part of what the weinstein book did was
it interviewed people who had never been
interviewed before who had been in the
communist party or been in the communist
underground or who knew whitaker
chambers or alger his they went to the
first six
interviewees in the book
and asked them what they thought and
every one of the six interviewees said
they had been misquoted misrepresented
or that their views had been otherwise
distorted by alan weinstein
well it often happens if you interview
people that they don't like the way
their interview turned out
so this by itself doesn't prove anything
but weinstein uh
said he had tapes he had taped all the
interviews he would make the tapes
public and this would show that he had
been
scrupulously fair in quoting them and
that they were wrong and saying they'd
been
misled this was about
uh this was in about 1980 that's more
than 25 years ago alan weinstein has
never made those tapes available to
his critics to the public
right now they've been donated to the
hoover institution at stanford
uh it has confirmation hearings to be
archivists of the united states this
issue came up
and
the committee insisted that he make
those tapes available as a condition of
becoming the archivist to clear up this
cloud
he donated them to the hoover
institution at stanford where at
at this moment i believe they are still
being processed
and it remains to be seen whether the
tapes actually are there
what the tapes actually say so you know
these are fairly serious charges the
charges themselves don't bother me so
much it's his failure let's call it his
refusal
to fulfill his obligation and share his
research materials
with other scholars in the field that's
actually required by the ethics of the
american historical association and the
american archivist association so
now the man who refused to who failed to
make his own archives available to
critics
is the archivist of the united states
appointed by george w bush in charge of
all the archives of the whole country
this bothers me
with technology with the ability of a
computer to
to check phrases that type of thing it
will we be finding more of these
examples
more specifically in the in the area of
plagiarism
well this is a fascinating uh
issue because of course if you put two
books into the computer
that are have different authors it is
possible to find all the identifi
identical phrases
and it's just a matter of where you wh
what you define as plagiarism
uh the guys i know i read about who
developed this program
uh you know if you said it at like four
words
you will find
hundreds of recurrences in the same four
words if you set it at six you find
dozens if you send it a ten
you find a couple you know so uh if you
turn it over the computers
uh it's it's it's gonna we're still
gonna need human eyeballs and human
judgment to say is this just the common
phrase is this a quote from a famous
speech that of course should be in this
book or is this
someone's original formulation that has
been taken by someone else and claimed
as their own work so computers
start to make it easier but it's still
going to take human judgment about
what's the significance of the fact that
these
sets of words are identical where do you
teach
i teach at uc irvine university of
california irvine which is south of los
angeles what do you teach i teach
american history 20th century u.s
history america since world war ii so
this is not exactly attached to
to uh what you teach no i do teach
graduate course on graduate methods and
a lot of
i think all history departments now
teach courses for majors and for
graduate students on historical methods
how to do research
and i would say there's a very simple
uh
moral in in my book historians of
trouble and that is
if you are making an argument in your
book that's going to make somebody
unhappy or angry make sure your
footnotes are correct
before you publish and if you don't want
anybody checking your footnotes it's
better to write about something nobody
cares about
when you when a member of the public
pulls a history book off the shelf
what kind of reassurance do they have
that it's
correct well supposedly the the
profession through the book review
process
has experts in the field evaluate all
the new books and there's you know a
dozen or two dozen scholarly journals
that eventually
get around to reviewing almost all of
the history books and one of the things
that reviewers are supposed to
determine is
how original is this and are there any
problems in the research now in practice
most reviewers write a 500 word review
you don't get paid for it
they're not going to check the footnote
so it's only if something seems off you
know this doesn't seem right to me this
footnote doesn't match up or this sounds
very familiar to me haven't i read this
somewhere before
so we're leaving it to the judgment of
scholars in all over the place and
a lot of things are going to get through
and some things are going to get picked
up what book is this for you what number
uh
four
and what are the other ones
um
well um i'm
best known for my
freedom of information lawsuit against
the fbi to get their files on john
lennon
i wrote a sort of political biography of
lenin
called come together john lennon in his
time
and then i published a book about the
litigation that included the 100 most
important documents from the john lennon
fbi file that's called give me some
truth that john lennon fbi file i have a
collection of essays called professors
politics and pop oh and i've got another
one i
how could i ever get i i wrote a book
about reconstruction in the in in
alabama called social origins of the new
south but that that was a long time ago
how did you get involved in the john
lennon fbi files
well it was i never intended this to be
a 25-year lawsuit or two books uh after
after lenin was shot in december 1980 i
was a historian a writer and i
uh wanted to write something about
lenin's engagement with the anti-war
movement in
give
the
united
chance uh years
and at that point a book had just been
published by uh david garrow
a famous biographer of martin luther
king called the fbi and martin luther
king and he had gotten the martin luther
king fbi file which turned out to be an
incredible gold mine of information
about what king was doing every day of
the last 10 years of his life and
historians were stunned by how rich this
material that david garrow had found and
i just sort of wondered i was very
impressed i wondered if there could be
anything like that about lennon since
nixon had tried to deport lenin in 1972
so i filed this freedom of information
request
the beginning of 1981
for just to see if they had a file on
john lennon and they replied yes they
had about
300 pages and they were going to
withhold about two-thirds of it under
the claim that releasing it would
endanger the national security of the
united states
now that seemed to be a ridiculous thing
to say about
you know 20 year old documents about a
dead rock star
and one of the great things about the
freedom of information act is it gives
requesters we are called the right to go
to federal court if you disagree
with an agency's decision to withhold
documents and ask the federal judge to
examine those documents and determine
whether they have been properly withheld
i was lucky enough to get the aclu to
represent me in
1983
we
filed the lawsuit to
get a federal judge to help us we didn't
really get the bulk of the documents
until 1997.
so that was too long
and even then that was the clinton
administration gave us most of it
that's what this book gave me some truth
is based on there were still 10
documents that they withheld
and uh those
those weren't released until december
2006
so just this last december chokes me up
just to think of how much time i had to
spend on this uh my idea was to write an
article in 1981 and and be over with it
but unfortunately it took another 25
years to resolve the case because the
aclu was very energetic very principled
very determined i would have given up
long long before if i hadn't had the
aclu and the book professors politics
and pop that's a collection of the
essays the journalism i did for uh the
nation uh
magazine and um
it's uh
from the 80s so um
the more recent one historian's in
trouble that's that's that's the
up-to-date one i ask you that because uh
the david horowitz has a book out called
indoctrination u in which he's very
critical
of what he contends to be a very
left-wing bias in in universities across
the country what do you think
well i've been following david horowitz
for a long time usually i see him here
at the book festival i haven't run into
him today usually he's he's around
um
david horowitz greatly exaggerates
uh the case that he's making it's true
that most people
in the
liberal arts at universities
vote democratic
now i'm not sure that this is really a
crime or you know a
political problem that requires some
kind of legislation to protect students
who are republicans which is sort of
where he
goes with this i mean i think in
business schools most of the professors
are republicans in medical school a lot
of the faculty is republicans
in the economics department a lot of
professors are republicans does this
mean we need laws protecting those
students to make sure their freedom
isn't abridged
my view is that if there are specific
charges of misconduct
if a student says my professor gave me
an f because i disagreed with his
political position or if a student says
my professor isn't lecturing on the
topic instead he's telling us who to
vote for in the presidential election
that is a very serious matter and the
universities should
investigate and punish anyone who's
guilty of that i don't think we need to
go with david horowitz and have state
laws
that require some kind of government
supervision of what goes on in the
classroom because i don't i don't think
there is that kind of of misconduct do
you have another book in you
uh this is a very very difficult
question right now i'm supposed to be
working on a new book about how the cold
war is being remembered and being
forgotten
but i'm just at the very beginning of
that so
i'm not sure what i think yet this is
the current book it's called historians
in trouble plagiarism fraud and politics
in the ivory tower the author professor
john weiner thank you very much thank
you
in 1876 the seventh cavalry of the u.s
army led by general george custer
engaged in battle with